sur le trajet de son prochain chantier
cet artisan à la boule au ventre le
temps qu'il va passer aujourd'hui dans
les embouteillages à paris sylvain
barreaud n'en a absolument aucune idée
[Musique]
est d'anticiper
au maximum
mais quand il s'agit de faire les
comptes les bouchons ont un prix ils
font perdre 9000 euros tous les mois son
entreprise
au delà de ce manque à gagner bah c'est
quand même du temps fond on paye mais ça
enfin comment laquelle on paie mes
salariés c'est du temps aussi un peu de
stress pour nos salariés parce qu'ils
ont toujours cette année à du bouchon
cette
angoisse pour reprendre mon moniteur
d'une première j'ai même de temps pour
rentrer ce soir les bouchons un argument
qui dissuaderait déjà un artisan sur 10
d'intervenir au centre de paris trouver
un électricien ou un plombier dans la
capitale pourrait donc bientôt devenir
le parcours du combattant excédé par ce
montant une association d'automobilistes
interpelle la mairie de paris sur le
temps passé dans les bouchons notre
mouvement s'appelle dit le anne et on
appelle tous les automobilistes bloqués
dans les bouchons à prendre leur
téléphone à connecter leur kit mains
libres dans la voiture et appeler anne
hidalgo en direct pour lui dire ce
qu'ils vivent sur la route
votre politique municipale est elle un
handicap pour vous dans cette campagne
vous savez j'ai comme beaucoup d'autres
villes dans le monde prie aussi un autre
sujet qui est très très important qui
est celui de la pollution qui dont les
dégâts sont incommensurables peut être
moins visible mais par exemple dans une
ville comme paris c'est 2500 morts liés
à la pollution atmosphérique par an
c'est beaucoup de coups un pour notre
système de santé et donc j'ai pris
évidemment le pari comme toutes les
grandes villes du monde et d'ailleurs
toutes les grandes villes du pays de
diminuer et eux
la circulation automobile polluantes
notamment aborder les parisiens ont le
sentiment d'avoir d'avis
que les bouchons aggrave la pollution
oui mais vous savez on est à l'ina et il
y a des ressources incroyables
impressionnante d'image que vous auriez
aussi pu passer dans l'histoire de paris
sur les bouchons parisiens et donc moi
je sais que le moment où on accomplit
une transformation on est dans le moment
de la transition c'est à dire on prend
conscience que la pollution ça tue et
que ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
d'ailleurs que tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer
et que les habitants des métropoles et
d'une ville comme paris réclame de
pouvoir respirer qu'en plus on est à un
endroit où il existe des transports en
commun un métro à moins de dix minutes à
pied de chez vous c'est la chance qu'ont
les parisiens et bien la décision que
j'ai prise c'est aussi une décision qui
a été validé par le suffrage des
parisiens par deux fois par deux fois
une première fois en 2014 une deuxième
fois en 2020 et d'ailleurs qui m'a valu
aussi beaucoup de reconnaissance non
seulement des parisiens mais aussi à
l'international je pense un certain
nombre de reconnaissances y compris à
l'onu qui me valent et qui nous valent à
paris d'être justement dans une ville la
ville de l'accord de paris qui a su
prendre à bras le corps cette question
de la pollution du changement climatique
et de la nécessité de changer nos modes
de fonctionnement bien sûr que quand
vous êtes dans le moment où on change
c'est compliqué il faut adapter il faut
ajuster il faut trouver aussi par
exemple des adaptations pour ce que l'on
a fait ce que j'ai fait pour tous les
artisans les accompagner dans l'achat de
véhicules propres il ya une grande
transformation de la mobilité à
accomplir dans notre pays ce que je
propose d'ailleurs dans mon programme ce
que nous faisons tous les maires des
grandes villes en france et dans le
monde n'est pas transposable par exemple
dans des territoires ruraux donc il faut
inventer d'autres solutions permettre
l'achat
véhicule électrique donc ça veut dire
aussi organisées sur tout le territoire
l'existence de bornes et
d'infrastructures permettant ces
véhicules électriques c'est mettre en
place comme je le propose un leasing
sociale c'est-à-dire un accompagnement
pour ceux qui vivent dans les
territoires ruraux qui n'ont pas de
transports en commun de pouvoir avoir
accès à une location de véhicules
électriques qui leur coûtera moins cher
d'ailleurs compte tenu du prix de
l'essence bref ce sont des
transformations absolument indispensable
et paris est une ville d'innovation
c'est une ville moderne qui accompagnent
évidemment les artisans mais qui ne
pouvait pas rester en arrière de la
transformation écologique
prenez ce qui s'est passé à rome qui est
une ville qui n'a pas connu les mêmes
transformations que paris rome a été
supplanté par qui par milan a nous paris
est devenu une référence mondiale qui a
attiré aussi beaucoup d'entreprises qui
sont venus à paris parce que justement
j'avais cette politique écologique très
très très avant gardiste et qui a montré
ses résultats
[Musique]